the roasting box was put together to
help people out because obviously we're
a preparedness company so we were able
to put together these emergency supplies
directly to help people just in case the
predictions come true from the media
about there being an issue at the
borders if the predictions are true and
we are going to potentially have issues
at the borders which could cause a
knock-on effect to our food supply if
that does happen we're going to have a
problem in the shops and so we just want
me to be people to be getting a little
bit prepared just in case yeah so the
box has about sixty main meals in it
then it's freeze-dried food so all you
do is you add water to it and it goes
back to its normal state it tastes
pretty good too so the food itself so
you have sixty meals but you also get an
additional forty eight portions of meat
products as well so that's diced chicken
and minced beef so you can create your
own food so altogether you get over 100
meals in the box and you also get a
water filter I can wear a water filter
and you also get a bottle of fire
lighting gel box is there
you